let me show you a handy tool Google  cloud shell the startup cloud shall  click on the terminal icon in Google  Cloud console at the bottom of your  browser terminal appears this terminal  is connected to a small temporary Linux  VM you can use this terminal to do  normal management tasks like creating  VMs or storage buckets building docker  images or accessing your cloud sequel DB  the VM that is created has most of the  tools you'll need to work on your  application including text editors  and compilers or interpreters forgo Java  Python Ruby and nodejs  I find cloud Joel to be especially  helpful when I'm on the road hotel and  conference Wi-Fi can be spotty but my  Kajal instance is sitting in a Google  Data Center so it is great for doing the  heavy handed tasks involved in managing  my projects I hope you try out cloud  shell soon